anfang april im nordrhein westfälischen
herford was dennis marx und drei anderen
bürgern passiert ist ziemlicher corona
irrsinn
die vier begegnen sich zufällig im
stadtpark und dafür kassieren alle ein
knöllchen pro person satte 230 euro ich
bin mir definitiv bis heute in keiner
schuld bewusst was falsch gemacht zu
haben denn es marx ist mit seinem welpen
samy im herforder erwiesen park
unterwegs
zufällig trifft der linda müller mit
ihrem hund wenig später sehen sie zwei
bekannte mann spricht kurz alle vier
halten natürlich die vorgeschriebenen
abstände zueinander ein wie aus dem
nichts tritt das ordnungsamt auf den
plan
für die herren vom amt ist das keine
zufällige begegnung im park sondern eine
illegale ansammlung nach paragraf 12 der
korona schutzverordnung für die
betroffenen ein schock und macht gefühl
man hat auch einmal das gefühl wie
einfältig schwerverbrecher behandelt zu
werden wo man sich nur einmal kurz
unterhalten hat nach dem bericht im
länderspiegel melden sich weitere
herforder bei uns die sich auch zu
unrecht bestraft fühlen jetzt rudert die
stadt zurück und ändert ihre politik in
sachen corona knöllchen komplett ist vom
ordnungsamt schauen uns jeden tag
natürlich genau an was darf der bürger
dass der bürger aber nicht eins zu eins
das nachvollziehen was darf ich heute
was darf ich morgen hat uns dazu
veranlasst zu sagen wir gehen jetzt
wieder mehr auf information und so sind
die mitarbeiter auch angewiesen worden
sie sollen die bürger informieren was
darfst du was darfst du nicht und nur im
äußersten notfall greifen sie dann hart
durch und wurden bußgelder verhängt
trotz dieser einsicht will das
ordnungsamt die bußgelder gegen dennis
marx und seine bekannten nicht
zurücknehmen
ich fühle mich verarschen kann das alles
gar nicht glauben was hier passiert
um die existenz ging es in wuppertal im
fall von alexander grünke seine firma
produziert diese aufsteller als spuck
schutz
doch vor einigen wochen kompost ein
rechtsanwalt aus österreich verbietet
alexander krüger seinen spuck spuk
schutz zu nennen und fordert 16.250 euro
der grund eine österreichische firma hat
sich die im begriff spuck schutz beim
europäischen amt für geistiges eigentum
wipo als marke eintragen lassen
unglaublich wer das wort gewerblich
verwendet braucht plötzlich eine
genehmigung das wäre genauso als würde
ich mir die kaffeemaschine schützen
lassen und alle die eine kaffeemaschine
vertreibe verklagen
das kann doch nicht sein der
länderspiegel beitrag ruf den
europaabgeordneten moritz körner auf den
plan
ja ich habe das bei ihnen in der sendung
gesehen und hab mir gedacht dass es
wirklich ein hammer
und das kann ja an der stelle nicht sein
und die hypo hat ihnen nicht geantwortet
aber ich habe gedacht
mehr als europaabgeordneten werden sie
antworten dann werden sie sich mit der
sache beschäftigen und deswegen habe ich
da entsprechend direkt ein briefing
geschickt die antwort vom eu amt für
geistiges eigentum kommt postwendend und
ist eindeutig der inhaber der marke
spuck schutz verfügt somit über kein
bedingungsloses recht anderen
unternehmen die benutzung dieses
begriffs zur beschreibung ihrer waren zu
verbieten eine wichtige nachricht für
alexander klinke der familienunternehmer
ist erleichtert wir fühlen uns auf jeden
fall im recht und beschädigt wir nutzen
begriff natürlich auch weiterhin den
begriff spruch schutz beschreiben für
unsere produkte
alexander grünke darf den begriff also
verwenden und spuck schutz darf in
europa auch weiterhin spuck schutz
gewarnt werden